>>> THIS MORNING A RETURN VISIT
FROM ANDY WEIR, THE FORMER
SOFTWARE ENGINEER FIRST BROKE
OUT WHEN HIS SELF-PUSHED DEBUT
NOVEL "THE MARTIAN."
IT WENT ON TO SELL 5 MILLION
COPIES AND WAS TURNED INTO A
BLOCKBUSTER MOVIE WITH MATT
DAMON.
NOW HE'S BACK WITH A RELUCTANT
ASTRONAUT WHO WILL HAVE TO USE
HIS INGENUITY TO SOLVE THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM IN THE WORLD,
THE POTENTIAL END OF THE WORLD.
THE BOOK IS CALLED "PROJECT HAIL
MARY."
>> "PROJECT HAIL MARY" IS A
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT STORY IDEAS
THAT I HAD THAT ENDED UP FITTING
TOGETHER REALLY WELL.
>> ASIDE FROM SHORT WALKS WITH
HIS DOG COCOA, ANDY WEIR HAS
SPENT MOST OF THE LAST YEAR PLUS
COOPED UP AT HOME.
THE TRAVEL HE'S AVOIDED IS MORE
THAN MADE UP FOR BY HIS LATEST
HERO, A TEACHER-TURNED-ASTRONAUT
WHO SPENDS MOST OF "PROJECT HAIL
MARY" 72 TRILLION MILES AWAY
FROM EARTH.
>> RYLAND IS OUR PROTAGONIST WHO
WAKES UP ABOARD A SPACESHIP WITH
COMPLETE AMNESIA.
HE COMES TO REALIZE IT'S HIS JOB
TO SAVE ALL OF HUMANITY FROM AN
EXISTENTIAL EXTINCTION LEVEL
EVENT.
>> A MYSTERIOUS ALGAE-LIKE
SUBSTANCE IS EATING AWAY AT THE
SUN SLOWLY PLUNGING OUR PLANET
INTO A NEW ICE AIMGE.
>> IT'S LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE IN
REVERSE.
>> NOT ENOUGH ENERGY IS HITTING
EARTH.
>> WE WON'T SPOIL ANYTHING BUT
WEIR'S KNOWLEDGE OF SCIENCE AND
SKILL AT STORY TELLING MAKE EVEN
THE MOST INSANE CONCEPTS SEEM
PLAUSIBLE.
>> OXYGEN LEVEL CRITICAL.
>> IN HIS BREAKOUT NOVEL "THE
MARTIAN" ASTRONAUT MARK WATNEY
PLAYED BY MATT DAMON IN THE 2015
FILM IS STRANDED ON MARS IN THE
YEAR 2035 AND FORCED TO
IMPROVISE TO SURVIVE.
>> SO, YEAH, I BLEW MYSELF UP.
>> AS IN "THE MARTIAN" THE LEVEL
OF TECHNICAL DETAIL AND
EXPLANATION IN "PROJECT HAIL
MARY" IS OFF THE CHARTS.
>> DO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND ALL THE SCIENCE
INVOLVED, OR DO YOU JUST WANT
THEM TO COME ALONG FOR THE
STORY?
>> MOSTLY I WANT THEM TO JUST
ENJOY THE STORY.
MY BOOKS ARE VERY SCIENCE HEAVY,
OBVIOUSLY, BUT I DESCRIBE THE
SCIENCE SO THAT THE READER CAN
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING.
I GET FEEDBACK FROM A LOT OF
READERS THAT HAVE LEARNED THAT A
LOT OF THEM JUST SKIM THE
SCIENCE.
YEAH, OKAY, THAT'S FINE.
I'M SURE THAT'S ALL RIGHT.
AT FIRST THAT ANNOYED ME BECAUSE
I WAS LIKE, OH, COME ON, IT TOOK
ME A LONG TIME TO WORK THIS OUT,
YOU SHOULD AT LEAST READ IT.
BUT THEN I REALIZED THIS IS
ACTUALLY AWESOME.
THE READER TRUSTS ME SO MUCH
THEY DON'T EVEN BOTHER READING
THE SCIENCE SECTIONS.
THEY ASSUME THAT IT'S ACCURATE
TO REAL SCIENCE.
THAT LEVEL OF TRUST FOR A READER
HAVING IN YOU, THAT'S JUST
AWESOME.
>> ARE YOU BUILDING A SPACESHIP
OVER HERE?
>> THESE ARE MY TABLE SAWS.
>> Reporter: WHEN HE'S NOT
WORKING OUT PLOT TWISTS YOU CAN
FIND HIM BUILDING CONTRAPTIONS
IN HIS GARAGE.
>> MY SECOND BOOK "ARTEMIS" ALSO
KNOWN AS THAT OTHER BOOK BY ANDY
WEIR TAKES PLACE ON THE MOON.
THIS SHOWS JUST TIME OF DAY LIKE
YOU'D EXPECT.
DOWN HERE IS THE MAIN MEAT OF
WHAT IT DOES.
THAT IS WHAT EARTH LOOKS LIKE
FROM THE MOON RIGHT NOW.
>> Reporter: HE WAS AN ENGINEER
BEFORE HE WAS A WRITER AND
REMAINS OBSESSED WITH THE
POSSIBILITIES HUMAN KNOW-HOW CAN
OPEN UP ON THIS WORLD AND
OTHERS.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE DURING THE
PANDEMIC MAYBE LESS PEOPLE HAVE
PAID ATTENTION TO --
>> FEWER.
YOU SNEAKY LITTLE DEVIL.
HAVE PAID ATTENTION TO NASA AND
SPACE ISSUES, I THINK.
SOMETIMES IT EVEN BECOMES A
POINT OF DEBATE WHERE PEOPLE GET
MAD ABOUT IT.
WHY DO YOU THINK MOVING FORWARD
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE TO PAY
ATTENTION TO?
>> FIRST OFF, A LOT OF GOOD
TECHNOLOGY COMES OUT OF IT.
SECOND OFF, WE WILL EVENTUALLY
REACH THE POINT WHERE COMMERCIAL
SPACE FLIGHT WILL BE AFFORDABLE
TO THE MIDDLE CLASS.
ONCE WE DO THAT, A NEW
MULTI-TRILLION INDUSTRY WILL BE
BORN.
FINALLY, IT'S A POINT OF PRIDE
FOR OUR SOCIETY SO IT GIVES US,
I GUESS, BRAGGING RIGHTS WHICH
SOUNDS SILLY.
IT'S A THING THAT EVERY
CIVILIZATION CARES ABOUT.
>> MAYBE I CAN AFFECT YOU A
LITTLE BIT WITH MY FAITH IN
HUMANITY.
>> Reporter: ANDY WEIR SHOWS IN
HIS BOOKS THAT HE DREAMS BIG,
AND NO MATTER WHAT, IS ALMOST
ALWAYS AN OPTIMIST.
>> I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT
2020 KINDA SUCKED, RIGHT?
BUT I PERSONALLY WOULD RATHER
LIVE THROUGH 2020 AGAIN THAN
LIVE THROUGH 1920.
NONE OF MY FRIENDS HAVE DIED OF
TYPHUS AND I'VE NEVER SEEN A NO
COLORED SIGN IN A SHOP WINDOW.
SO IF YOU PICK ANY TWO YEARS IN
HISTORY, YOU'LL ALWAYS PROBABLY
PREFER TO LIVE IN THE ONE THAT'S
LATER.
HUMANITY JUST MAKES HUMANITY
BETTER OVER TIME.
FOR INSTANCE, HERE'S SOMETHING.
I'M GOING TO MAKE A BOLD
PREDICTION.
I PREDICT THAT COVID-19 WILL BE
THE LAST PANDEMIC IN HISTORY.
>> REALLY?
>> YEAH.
MRNA VACCINES ARE VERY, VERY
FAST TO CREATE NOW.
YOU CAN CREATE THE VACCINE IN A
MATTER OF WEEKS, NOT MONTHS, NOT
A YEAR.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THE MAGNITUDE OF WHAT HAPPENED
IN THE SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY IN
RESPONSE TO COVID.
IT'S NOT -- THEY DIDN'T JUST
STEP UP THEIR GAME, THEY
INVENTED A NEW TECHNOLOGY FOR
HOW TO DEAL WITH IT.
SO NOT ONLY THAT, BUT ALSO THE
CONCEPT OF A PANDEMIC IS NOW
PART OF THE PUBLIC
CONSCIOUSNESS.
EVERYBODY NOW UNDERSTANDS WHAT A
PANDEMIC IS.
IF WE GET ANOTHER PANDEMIC
WITHIN THE NEXT 40 YEARS OR SO,
THIS ONE WILL STILL BE A LIVING
MEMORY AND PEOPLE WILL KNOW HOW
TO ACT.
THERE WON'T BE THAT LEARNING
PROCESS.
AND, I BELIEVE, IF WE HAVE A
PANDEMIC LATER THAN THAT, OUR
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY WILL BE ABLE
JUST TO STOP IT IN ITS TRACKS.
>> YOU ARE A SEER OF SEERS, ANDY
WEIR.
>> I ALSO PREDICT THAT WE MIGHT
NEVER AGAIN HAVE A DAY WHEN
THERE ARE NO HUMANS IN SPACE.
>> WOW.
>> LIKE THE LAST TIME THERE WERE
NO HUMANS IN SPACE WAS SOMETIME,
I THINK, IN THE EARLY 2000s.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WAS THE LAST
TIME THAT EVERY LIVING HUMAN
BEING WAS ON EARTH.
>> THE END OF PANDEMICS, THE
CONTINUATION OF HUMANS IN SPACE.
IS THERE A TRIFECTA?
>> I DON'T KNOW ABOUT A
TRIFECTA, I DON'T KNOW.
>> THAT'S PROBABLY GOOD ENOUGH
FOR NOW.
>> I DON'T HAVE A THIRD ONE.
WE'LL HAVE TO STICK WITH A
BIFECTA.
>> THE TRIFECTA WAS CORRECTING
YOU.
THAT'S THE TRIFECTA.
>> ON DERBY DAY I'LL TAKE THE
BIFECTA OR THE TRIFECTA.
HE'S A FASCINATING GUY.
THE COOL THING ABOUT "PROJECT
HAIL MARY," I'M NOT ADVOCATING
YOU SKIM, BUT IT'S 400 PLUS
PAGES.
YOU CAN MOVE OVER SOME OF THE
SCIENCE STUFF QUICKLY IF IT'S
NOT ENGAGING YOU.
I ENJOY IT.
HE MOVES THE STORY ALONG SO WELL
AND TELLS A GREAT STORY SO IT'S
GREAT CHECKING OUT.
>> SEEING THE WAY HE CORRECTED
YOU, HE'S THE TYPE OF GUYS THAT
WATCHES SCI-FI MOVIES AND SAYS
THAT WOULD NEVER HAPPEN THAT WAY
BECAUSE OF THE SCIENCE SO HE'S
TRYING TO BACK UP HIS OWN WOR